we will see what kind of doctor strange
you are
there's been more leaked trailers for
doctor change than a multiverse of
madness and so much has been revealed so
let's break it down and get straight
into it the first trailer begins with
mordo saying doctor strange the
illuminati will see you now before we
cut to new footage of wanda defending
herself from these soul-looking
creatures that are trying to attach to
her she just blows them away with ears
like they are nothing showing her true
power as the skull at which these
creatures look to be the same thing that
will follow in zombie strange or
possibly they are defending something
sacred or maybe they're summoned by
zombie strange but i would say they're
probably defending whatever they're
trying to both get we then have two new
shots which show a lot the first shot is
of a captain marvel variant where she is
seen attacking wonder now i know a lot
of people were thinking this was
superior iron man but right here this
confirms that it is not we then have a
review of captain carter from the what
if series now i was actually quite
surprised that they have shown another
cameo in the trailer but nevertheless
it's very very exciting to see this we
also see captain carter with a jet pack
which he has used for stabilization
purposes now this could be stark
technology but it's unknown and in the
background we can see wonder here which
captain carter is no doubt fighting
wonder actually looks very relaxed here
and as we know wonder right now could be
one of the most powerful people in the
whole entire multiverse so this battle
here probably isn't too much of a
struggle for her as we can see her you
know looking quite relaxed here we then
have new dialogue from professor x which
i'll play for you now we will see what
kind of doctor strange you are we then
see him in his yellow chair which makes
me think is this professor x straight
after animated tv show or is this just
another comic accurate representation
either way it's really exciting to see
more of professor x and i'm quite
surprised how much it actually showed in
this trailer the next trailer begins
with a dialogue line from wonder saying
stephen strange we then see steven
strange revolt off the top of a balcony
as he changes into his dr strange outfit
as he is seen wearing a suit beforehand
i'm going to guess this is at the start
of the movie where he's attending
christine's wedding but then gagantos
attacks the streets and then stephen
strange jumps into action winder then
says it's about time you show up until
we cut to new footage of the gangantos
battle and before this trailer ends off
we see a new shot of wonder casting a
spell of some kind showing her true
power as the scarlet witch the next tv
spot begins with a portal open and in
the snow looking environment which we've
seen previously and walking out of a
portal we see wong and wonder until we
cut to new footage of america chavez and
defender strange at the start of the
movie where they're running away from
this ribbon creature where he defender
strange say jump as i both jump into the
distance towards this object in the
background which i believe is the book
of verse then we have a very quick new
shot of defender strange yet again in
the last tv spot trailer we've been
given it begins with doctor strange
saying doctor strange saying wonder i
could use an avenger which in turn
wonder says this is going to be fun
before cut into the temple scene where
we see them engaging in battle i believe
this person they're shooting at up in
the sky is no other than wonder herself
just because if we splash together
footage here looks like wonder is
attacking them we then have a very quick
new shot of mordor attacking doctor
strange and i believe this isn't a
mortar we know but a variant of him and
to end off this trailer we have new
footage of wong and zombie strange we
see wong trekking up a set of stairs on
the mountain top till he sees zombie
strange in the background and which he
responds with i don't even want to know
and in the distance we see zombie
strange doing a spell of some kind it
looks like he's containing these
creatures which we have seen attack
wonder before or possibly he is
summoning them it's hard to know what is
exactly going on here but only time
would tell me won't have to wait too
much longer as the movie releases very
very soon anyway that print off covers
everything for this breakdown so let me
know what you think of this new footage
in the comment section below and if you
did enjoy please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching